[Music]
but anyway I'm with this family I felt
like I was on The Bachelor kaley cuoco
opens up about the adventurous bachelor
style date that left her completely
terrified
my boyfriend's a daredevil loves to all
the stuff so he told me we're so excited
midweek we're gonna go on a canyon swing
sounds harmless right yeah not so much
Kaylee explained the death-defying
experience on Wednesdays tonight's show
here's what happened when she went on
vacation to New Zealand with her
boyfriend Carl cook and his family and
they attempted the canyon swing you're
supposed to just walk off and it's a six
second freefall and then you swing for
ten minutes so as we get to do Django
really dangle the canyon dangle yeah
that you're gonna see your family again
the experience was reminiscent of the
high octane date scene on The Bachelor
Kaylee's favorite show are you ready to
take this can you jump off with him you
know this is the next step in your
relationship I'm like am I gonna get the
rose the risky stunt was frightening but
clearly worth it it was horrible so
horrible but it really was I got the
rose yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you